el gobierno de Benjamín netanyahu
anunció esta madrugada seis medidas
represivas contra los palestinos sobre
todo a aquellos en Jerusalén tras el
ataque a la salida de una sinagoga que
dejó siete muertos y otro tiroteo
posterior que causó dos heridos estas
medidas apuntan no solo a los
responsables sino a sus familiares pues
buscan quitarles el acceso al seguro
social e incluso revocarles sus
documentos israelíes o tarjetas de
residencia lo que al final los forzaría
a marcharse a cisjordania a radicarse
allí a esto se suma la demolición de la
casa del atacante y un refuerzo de
tropas militares y policiales pero sin
duda el punto más controvertido es dar
más licencias de armas a civiles
incluidos los colonos que habitan en
asentamientos ilegales en cisjordania
ocupada una decisión que contradice el
pedido inicial del propio netanyahu de
no tomarse la justicia por la mano pero
que complace al extremista y tamar Benji
suministro de seguridad que ha pedido
los israelíes armarse y va a presentar
ante el parlamento un proyecto para que
se aplica la pena de muerte a quienes
Israel considera terroristas medidas que
ya anhelaba la extrema derecha religiosa
y que sin duda se han acelerado con
estos dos ataques en este clima anoche
se produjo una ola de ataques de colonos
israelíes en la provincia de nablus las
autoridades locales registraron 144
actos de vandalismo con quema de
vehículos de comercios y hasta una
vivienda y son actos que habitualmente
no acarrean consecuencias para sus
agresores y todo esto ocurre cuando hoy
se cumple un agitado primer mes del
nuevo gobierno de netanyahu que ya deja
al menos 30 palestinos muertos en
cisjordania ocupada y que también se
enfrenta a una ola de protestas en
rechazo a un plan de reforma judicial
que busca reducir El poder del tribunal
supremo